[Música]
de 16 años se convirtió en una de las
más recientes Víctimas de las armas de
fuego en Estados Unidos El joven afro
estadounidense timbró por error en la
casa de un hombre que respondió
disparándole en la cabeza y aunque logró
sobrevivir su caso vuelve a poner sobre
la mesa la necesidad de una regulación
de estos artefactos de acuerdo con
Gumball una iniciativa sin fines de
lucro en lo que va de 2023 la violencia
Armada ha dejado más de 13.000 muertos
en Estados Unidos para hablar de este
tema saludamos a Maribel balbín ella es
representante de la organización Rubén
gun violence en Florida señora Maribel
bienvenida a directo América
Muchas gracias muy buenos días a todos y
empiezo preguntándole Cuáles son los
principales o las principales causas del
aumento de la violencia de armas en los
hogares estadounidenses Durante los
últimos años
desafortunadamente lo que hemos visto es
que las ventas de armas se aceleró mucho
durante la pandemia para muchos
estadounidenses su idea de seguridad y
protección es la propiedad de un arma de
fuego por lo que continuamos teniendo
entonces tiroteos masivos constantemente
porque es la cantidad de artefactos que
hay en la población Mientras más acceso
existe pues más problemas tenemos en
este momento tenemos 400 millones de
armas en este país por lo tanto es un
problema que se agrava por días y que no
le podemos encontrar una solución debida
para poder controlarlo hay varias
organizaciones que han concluido por
ejemplo que la violencia de armas afecta
desproporcionadamente a minorías étnicas
y raciales en Estados Unidos qué
políticas son necesarias para abortar
este racismo estructural
Así es por ejemplo hay números como que
el 54% de los afroamericanos y el 27% de
los hispanoamericanos dicen que un amigo
cercano o un familiar ha experimentado
ha experimentado violencia con arma de
fuego en este país en los últimos cinco
años en comparación con el 13% de los
estadounidenses blancos en general el
21% de los adultos de Estados Unidos
tienen un vínculo personal con la
violencia Armada como haber sido
amenazados por alma o por haber sido
víctimas específicamente
la violencia Armada definitivamente como
muchas organizaciones están trabajando
en este tema eran parte una historia de
raza y geografía a nivel nacional la
tasa de homicidios para hombres negros
es de 30.7 por 100.000 y para hombres
blancos es Dos punto cuatro por cien mil
por lo tanto es una gran disparidad que
existe entre nuevamente raza y geografía
tiene mucho que ver dónde vive la
persona la pobreza Está identificada
también como una
impactos para el problema de la persona
que tienen armas y cómo resuelven una
diferencia que normalmente se podría
hacer con una conversación hoy día
tienes el alma disponible y la estamos
utilizando señora Balvin está en el
imaginario de los estadounidenses que
las armas son sinónimos de seguridad sin
embargo la tenencia de esta se ha
traducido en una violencia desmedida
cada vez mayor estar armado garantiza
estar más seguro o responde esto más
bien a un vacío del estado en
responsabilidad de proteger a sus
ciudadanos es complicada es complicada
la la dinámica no la persona se siente
como tú preguntas Este nosotros somos
muchas encuestas y hablamos con muchas
personas piensa que ellos tienen que
protegerse Así mismo y a su familia
Porque sí algunas veces dicen que no
están seguros de que la seguridad social
lo va a proteger eso no tiene en
realidad
no hay pruebas de que eso es cierto
hemos visto como por ejemplo en un lugar
donde tiene alguien con un arma a saltar
y hay otra persona con un arma pues No
necesariamente puede reaccionar a a ese
a ese momento no porque en realidad Tú
tienes que tener un entrenamiento como
lo tiene en la seguridad la seguridad de
la policía y todo eso Por lo tanto es
una falsa seguridad que la persona tiene
con esta arma porque en realidad no es
que estamos en el oeste todo aquí en los
Estados Unidos no y mucho menos en en la
en los ciudades urbanas donde no es
necesario que tú tengas que tener un
alma encima Para poder protegerte Pero
sí hay muchas personas que eso es lo que
ellos piensan que la única forma de
protegerse a sí mismo y a su familia es
teniendo un arma no solamente en la casa
pero encima en su cuerpo en estos
momentos hablemos entonces de esta
percepción que tienen los
estadounidenses y aquí entramos a hablar
también entonces de la segunda enmienda
de la Constitución que protege el
derecho a aportar y a usar armas cree
que de alguna forma sea mal interpretado
esta normativa a lo largo de los años
estamos en una conversación muy intensa
en cuanto a la segunda enmienda
obviamente desde el año 77 se empezaron
a discutir y vio en un caso en la Corte
Suprema donde entonces decidieron que sí
el arma era un derecho individual en
lugar de como vemos en lo que es la
narrativa de la segunda enmienda que
habla de una milicia bien regulada eso
Tal como tal no es necesario en este
momento ni existe pero sí la corte o la
corte conservadora
decidió hacerle caso en ese momento a lo
a la en array al National association la
asociación del rifle nacional que aunque
En aquellos momentos era en realidad una
organización no política pero debido a
la conversación y a los casos que se
llevaron a la corte se ha convertido en
la mayor organización defensora de este
de este derecho el cual que sí está un
poco mal interpretado porque aún algunos
de los miembros de la Corte Suprema
hablaron que si la segunda enmienda nos
dice que podemos tener armas en los
Estados Unidos pero hay también
regulaciones hay un espacio para tener
regulaciones y en esas regulaciones es
donde tenemos el problema de quién
considera que es una
que impacta la segunda enmenda y quien
dice que no que es parte de la segunda
enmienda el poder regular por ejemplo
aquí en la Florida ahora mismo hemos ido
para atrás unos cuantos años al permitir
que las personas tengan una pistola
encima sin tener un permiso especial ni
un entrenamiento especial que se
requería anteriormente o sea hemos
perdido muchos Campos en ese en este
momento porque hay una una Euforia por
este
derecho que tenemos de la segunda
enmienda y desafortunadamente es algo
que se ha convertido en algo político no
lo que no debe ser porque en realidad lo
que tenemos es una crisis de salud
pública porque cuando tú tienes que
cuarenta mil personas al año están
muriendo debido en específico es porque
tenemos un problema y Y eso es lo que lo
desafortunadamente los conservadores o
los republicanos en este momento no
quieren verlo de esa forma y estamos en
este problema que tenemos hoy que son
tenemos más más tiroteos este año que
días en el año en esta en este momento
en los Estados Unidos O sea que es
definitivamente mi organización y muchas
otras consideran que es una crisis de
salud pública y que se debe enfrentar de
esa forma pero no tenemos el apoyo
bipartidista que necesita este tema
usted trae colación está puja entre
demócratas y republicanos que se ha
presentado en el congreso que divide al
país además sobre el porte de armas cree
que esta polarización política
contribuye de algún modo al fenómeno que
estamos viendo sobre el aumento en la
violencia de armas
definitivamente porque como decíamos al
principio la
el hecho de que tengamos tantas armas no
que caen en las manos equivocadas que
caen en manos de entrenamiento y que
caen en manos de personas que tienen
problemas la mayor cantidad en realidad
de personas que mueren en los Estados
Unidos por armas son suicidios o sea es
casi la mitad de toda la otra todos los
otros aspectos que que se consideran en
en Casos de de muerte por armas no pero
es nuevamente la accesibilidad el hecho
de que cualquiera puede tener un arma
que cada día tenemos menos restricciones
en eso eh Y el otro lado de la de la
conversación es que debemos tener
restricciones que debemos eliminar
ciertas armas como es el rifle de asalto
que se utiliza tanto en esta tiroteos
masivos pero que desafortunadamente el
partido republicano que tiene control de
la cámara en este momento no quiere oír
ninguna conversación el año pasado el
presidente biden pudo pasar una ley
donde hicimos algunas cosas pero no es
suficiente y hasta que no que se
considere como te decía anteriormente
como lo que es que es una crisis de
salud pública para los Estados Unidos lo
hicimos cuando se puso por ejemplo el
cinturón de seguridad en los automóviles
era la causa que los niños en la de
Pequeños en los Estados Unidos la mayor
causa de muerte y se fue haciendo la
investigación o sea poniendo en reglas y
se controló de la forma de la misma
forma que hicimos eso tenemos que
hacerlo con las armas de fuego claro un
debate extenso y que seguramente
continuará perpetuándose era Maribel
balbín representante de la organización
en Florida Muchas gracias por
acompañarnos en directo Muchas gracias Y
ustedes televidentes hacemos una pequeña
pausa ya regresamos con nuestro último
bloque en directamente
[Música]